now I'm gonna hold that up okay season
inside please why is it yellow because
it's a comfort chicken obviously he's
corn and if you eat lots of corn yellow
turn yellow now what are those
chickpeas chickpeas yeah have a little
tasty
rice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please now
chilies
can you hear that noise was that made
the seeds have come out
the tops I'm gonna add the chilies to
chickpeas in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest I love my zest
the absolutely right a little glug of
olive oil
come on house don't worry about your
nails now come on baby you can do it
now time
off all those wonderful little buds
see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that
Target what's this
slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little bit
and a CD yeah so imagine that flavor
going into the chicken
that's gonna be delicious now nice soft
butter in with a tarragon
lovely yeah
yeah and when you gently
your fingers through there
and just so we can get that butter under
there but I need those small beautiful
little hands
what's wrong yeah okay come on holes
I want you
a nice handful of butter
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah butter running down and the breasts
stay nice and moist and like you
yeah all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
good and push down
okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic
should I wash my hands no not yet
we made a garlic
onto the tray now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper make your skin nice and crispy
and then I'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that will stop the butter from
burning and look at that please open up
the door thank you everybody and she
goes
beautiful good job
all right let's start off with the
marinade Tamarind paste in first
all that into there all of that yeah all
of that okay
so two tablespoons of palm sugar please
a heated sugar
um it's a really good question here it's
a natural palm sugar and it's perfect
for marinades how many wings you think
you've eaten so far at the age of 13. oh
I eat probably 50 a year 50 a year yeah
something like that a nice sprinkle of
chili flakes depends how hot you like
them
don't forget the girls you know they
start complaining when you get them too
hot
come you love hot food so
I don't know
so in there we've got palm sugar
Tamarind paste chili flakes
some garlic one nice tablespoon
fish sauce please check this is looking
really good isn't it and then a couple
tablespoons of oil for marinade
in
how nice little taste
not your finger jack
ET
that's really good right Wings in get
your hands in there and start rubbing in
the marinade please okay so the secret
now is to coat
the chicken wings and all that marinade
yeah yeah
how long do you leave them in here do
you want but longer the better
cover that
when Clinton
excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going
[Applause]
all right so they're marinated now if
you take the tray out people
thank you and then we're gonna put some
tin foil on there thank you
so
pour that in half
it stops them from sticking and that'll
stop
the wings from burning so from there got
them really dipped in that marinade and
try and get the wing like that and just
sort of scoop it
no like that to get that really nice
glaze on there
and then just
yeah
it's all that garlic will roast
and we've got all those wings
beautifully
done I can make them ready for the oven
170 25 to 30 minutes
come on
accent
we're gonna start off with Browning
oh
the chicken off nicely pan on get that
nice and hot what I want you to do for
me first is to season
a chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you so that's on one side then we
turn the chicken over
so we season it on the other side salt
good girl and pepper nice
now this is almost like a chicken stew
okay what's that there
[Music]
time time good girl what's that one
there
that's right Rosemary and because this
is quite a rustic French dish we don't
need to chop everything so you get the
garlic
and you just bash it like that now smell
hmm that's right so that's nice and hot
put a tablespoon of olive oil in there a
couple of gloves
one two good cow Chicken in
it and you lay away
you got that nice and brown getting good
at this you are
skin side down so we got the color on
the skin now I just want you to cut the
mushrooms in half the belly please okay
these are Chestnut mushrooms there are
lots of different types of mushrooms out
there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms which one's
your favorite one of my favorites is the
girol mushroom I like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle put pesto and cheese in it and
then we bake them oh so I want you to
sprinkle the pancetta over the chicken
please
not yet because I'm gonna get some color
on the chicken first
okay
and as that pancetta
started to cook down to put a really
nice flavor on the chicken yeah yeah so
we're sort of soaking everything okay
like garlic in please good girl just
throw them in
and then we just sprinkle the mushrooms
on top of that good girl
and then there's a rosemary and can you
get your fingers like that and you pull
it down you take it all off
hold it
put it down good cow so now you've got
the nice little Rosemary sprigs and we
do the same with the thyme now the thyme
flour is a little bit smaller what
different flavors do they give so the
thyme is a little bit sweeter okay and
the Rosemary a little bit more Savory
which ones you like I like them both
because they both give a nice name don't
they so bay leaf in
I'd like you to put that Rosemary and
Thyme in there please
lovely sprinkle over right I'd like you
to stand back now because we're going to
flambe this I do not want to get those
little slippers caught on fire what are
their names
and Judith Judith nice okay great ready
yeah in with a brandy
and then just tilt the pan gently
[Music]
whoa whoa how cool is that
beautiful a bit like a cauldron oh the
cognac has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol anywhere so we've got a really
nice deep rich flavor I'm gonna add my
chicken stock you know Rumple likes that
not much
ah Rumple it up well he likes chicken
stock yes when he's a good boy he gets
him he gets it in his um with his
biscuit it's gone and like wow really
quickly simmer and reduce the stock for
around 10 minutes on the Fried Chicken
traditionally it's always gonna be done
with the dark meat the brown meat so
you've got that nice sort of drum here
and this bit Yeah thigh cooking on the
bone as well keeps it even more moist so
first things first salt pepper please
buttermilk in it's brilliant for
marinating the chicken if you can put
this buttermilk over your chicken the
night before the more it tenderizes the
chicken and starts to sort of really
relax the chicken and puts a really nice
sort of creamy soury flavor in there so
might stick that in the fridge first
please now we're gonna
roll the chicken out of the buttermilk
into the flour so that's why it's nice
and crispy and blistery on the outside
Okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yes
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this is a smoked paprika so that
gives that little bit of sort of uh
maybe it's yeah a little bit Yeah spice
that's right a little bit of heat and
this one my favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but the heat works
brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally I used a lot
in the steaks onion powdered garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please only get the pan on now
two centimeters of oil this is a really
good mix for fish as well goujons biting
a nice spicy
texture helps fish so first thing is we
just shake off some of the buttermilk
lay that down yeah okay really important
to get them covered completely okay in
the flour yeah okay so I love fried
chicken do you
now lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you nice and
gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through now very
carefully turn them over please yeah
cool
can we have this every day Jack fry
chicken every day no definitely not it's
a treat and it's shallow fried so once
every three weeks yeah sounds great to
me yeah now offer the gas okay yeah
paper ready okay onto the paper
first of all
and turn on the grill reason why we're
using the thighs I.E the brown lead if
so it doesn't go dry The Season's nice
[Music]
salt pepper
olive oil and turn them over please
come on get your hands in there good
don't worry about your nail varnish so
there's no bones in there so the chicken
will cook really quickly
why'd you do it since they're done skin
side down first that'll stop the chicken
from going dry and it'll get it really
nice and crispy
good see the way it's marked the skin
now yeah got all that really nice flavor
in there as well and we'll determine
every 13 minutes how much do you love
chicken lots lots you'll serve that some
really nice chickpeas so it's all going
to make a little dressing okay one nice
teaspoon of mustard in please a little
bit of olive oil
a touch of salt
and pepper
give that a really good mix
and then you just squeeze Lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
it's nice that is delicious
now look at that chicken now
beautiful nice and crispy as well turn
the gas down now and leave that chicken
to griddle right let's get the chickpeas
done shall we yeah
so we've got peculio Peppers so these
are roasted smoked Spanish Peppers now a
little taste
I would like you chop up the
kettleberries
you take off the the top I'm going to
slice them in half like that wash your
fingers I will okay so these are small
tequila Peppers yeah it's a bit sweeter
there you go put your fingers please
wash your fingers please tuck them in
three finger rule come on Holly you know
the three fingers are all I've been
telling you that since six months old
good girl you're fast honey yeah yeah in
fact you're faster than Jack don't tell
him go get him upset should I put the
peppers in yes please thank you
good and then give it a little mix for
your fingers
please
love it rump holes ow come on out out
get out every time this food is always
there he smells it from mile away
a chicken grilling it's inside down why
is it on skin side down because it keeps
getting moist he's a really nice and
moist that's right